[Music]
meat and weaker he's the next big
artists to come out of the Renaissance
period until on his opening night
[Music]
it's art has been mysteriously
[Music]
can you help Enrique located missing art
pieces before his gas in the right
you're his only chance may be taken
seriously as a true artist at the
Venetian spirit
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Jenna's again made another questionable
game title for part of my university
degree this game was made under the
theme of Renaissance party which is
quite difficult to come up with a
narrative for but as I was working in a
team this time under the title of game
designer it was my job to come up with
the narratives project manage the team
and put the game in unity and make sure
that the code was okay I was pakoda it
was great working with the team this
time you can check out who I worked with
to make this game possible in the
description as well as downloading the
games from a link in the description I'd
love to hear what you think of this oh
please bear in mind that we only made
this game within three month period I'm
more than happy to share things with you
as always and I'm working on more games
in the future but hopefully you can see
how much I can progress anyway have a
lovely day or evening sighs
[Music]